[Music]
you brought a special piece of art with
you I understand you've been working on
can we bring that out right now I
understand you made this for your
appearance
well we ready to unveil this or sure
well I've been watching this show for a
while and and your old shows and I
remember back whenever you went to
Houston because it used to be aired at 2
o'clock in the made me a TV went to the
streets and there was nobody on the
streets because nothing was happy was
trying to find who was watching my show
we were inside watching your show oh wow
well I was there come to my house and
come inside and seen the show but I've
also always seen that you know it in
shows and documentaries and whatnot that
you have really good taste in music and
all the rockabilly influences on the
staff that man I'm crazy about it and so
I kind of channeled a little bit of that
and hope that kind of speaks to that a
little why don't you go by and unveil it
for us I'm excited to see this this is a
lipstick rockabilly Conan and I'm very
honored that you do that happy
[Applause]
[Music]
that's fantastic Natalie you said it's
not quite done you were going to show us
your technique kind of cash it off like
only I actually make a lot of my own
lipsticks okay and this is I've used
several different colors on this but one
of the ones in particular my husband
actually helps me name them sometimes
and this is a bastard beige bastard age
say bastard beige and being finished off
in bastard beige it happens sometimes
all right and so you're putting that on
yeah now you're going to which part
needs a touch-up a little bit of that
okay well over the hair I want to see
this happen like I said it's it's not
the most flattering thing and it gets
pretty messy but it's for your art do
what you got to do right I feel like
such a creep right now
[Applause]
you're welcome yes I think it needs a
little something else women's the last
time you you put on a little lipstick oh
you want me to add something to it yes
okay sure there we go
[Applause]
oh yeah
this this is this is what happens in the
this is what happens in the
dressing-room minutes after the show is
table what do you want me to put this
just maybe a bit on the big pucker no I
feel like the creep
[Applause]
[Music]